okay so I made a video a little while
ago explaining that Frieza doesn't
actually kill his employees and you know
what's more is it's actually not a bad
place to work it's got some great
benefits we're going to be dipping into
video game Lord trademark here but
there's a lot of reasons to believe that
the Frieza force is a better place to
work than you'd think like did you know
that according to the Xenoverse games
they get maternity leave that's better
than America and that's nothing compared
to the Health Care Medical Equipment
free apparel and profit sharing bonuses
they got now to be fair that last one
comes from Fighters and the English
translation for that game is insanely
bad a story for another day perhaps but
still down on your luck and need a job
consider the Frieza Force this video has
been sponsored by the Frieza Force